[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where they all float the full
official trailer for each chapter to you
has just dropped and it looks like the
entire film isn't clowning around with
the face down between the losers Club
and Pennywise the clown finally going
down the last trailer had a bit where it
looks like what happens when you get out
of the shower without a towel but this
update looks infinitely more terrifying
there's a hell of a lot to unpack from
this new look at the film and throughout
this video I'll be doing a general
breakdown of the trailer and then kind
of going into all the information that
you need to know about the movie itself
this is full spoilers ahead so if you
don't want to know anything about the
movie or what could happen going off the
source material then I highly recommend
that you turn off now without the way
thank you for clicking the video now
let's get into my it chapter 2 trailer
breakdown okay so this is kind of
touched upon in the book and that penny
wise basically puts a spell over the
entire town that sort of makes people
very nonchalant to what's going on and
it was always kind of a point of
contention when I was reading the
original story that why why have these
people forgotten what happened only
about 30 years ago I mean it was a
massively terrifying thing for them I
think it would shock me for the rest of
my life yet somehow these people they
don't remember and makes the only one
who does and they have a very vague
memory but actually turns out that penny
wise is sort of controlling all of dairy
and putting basically this sort of a
hypnosis over the entire town that is
one of the main reasons that the police
don't investigate further into the
missing children and there's a lot of
sort of basically penny wise is using
his incredible psychic abilities to make
everyone very ignorant to what's
actually going on in the city so I'm
glad that they touched upon this because
it wasn't really mentioned in the
original TV show but yeah this is a
great little nod to it
yeah and you see that people are still
going missing and five years old you can
see there and obviously penny wise is
operating once more but the police
probably don't care because he still has
everyone under this kind of spell
and here we see the Barons flooding
[Music]
but don't worry if you're drowning right
because lifeguard Pennywise is there to
save you some people stick around I'll
not put you through my Baywatch
impression but yeah Pennywise is still
operating and he's killing lots of
people by the looks of it and here is
the losers Club re meeting for the first
time in 30 years it happens at the
Chinese restaurant which is a massive
scene in the book it's kind of when they
all get back together and this scene was
actually shown a lot more in detail at
San Diego comic-con they have made some
slight alterations to it from the
original source material but I'm
definitely looking forward to watching
it play out once more as it's a great
scene that starts off very happy and
then gets very sinister now one thing
you will notice is that one of the
chairs is empty and I'm just gonna give
some massive spoilers now so if you
don't want to know anything about the
film this is your last chance to turn up
this is a big spoiler but Stan actually
kills himself when Mike calls him purely
because he's just so terrified to go
back there and face down penny wise so
yeah this is a little highlight here
that he's not gonna be in the film as
much as you think and his suicide sort
of brings them together and they realize
like damn we really need to pull this
off
and if you just go back there there was
a slight flash of Beverly walking in the
rain now what happened in the book is
that basically her she's basically gone
on to date her father in some ways
they're not not literally but basically
a guy who's very abusive to her he hits
her they she gets the call from Mike to
go back to Derry and she kindly like she
just accepts it she's like yeah Nia go
and and her husband I think it's a
husband he doesn't really understand
what's going on actually it's not a
husband it's just a boyfriend
he doesn't understand what's going on
and they have a massive blazing row and
in the book it's a very big scene
Beverley kind of storms out in the
pouring rain without any shoes on which
is clearly what she's doing here Ben got
hot bill got very broish squash yeah
James MacAvoy Eddie's still worried and
Mikey's just checking out the scene
Ritchie has became Bill Hader and he's
also gotten to do stranger things so
well done
right and this is another scene that was
shown at San Diego comic-con and
basically it's a fairground where bill
sees a child wandering into a house of
mirrors and he's getting chased down by
Pennywise and he sort of runs in after
him which we see in this scene now this
is genius because imagine going into a
house of mirrors to face down penny wise
it's absolutely terrifying and yet I
cannot wait to see how this comes across
in the movie because this this has the
potential to be the scariest scene in
the film I think it's not in the source
material we've not seen it in the TV
show and it definitely could go down
massively here
and there is Pennywise doing his best
impression of a KISS concert that we did
see a Funko pop up this with his tongue
hanging out so yeah it's good to see
this has made it for the film in this
scene now often in films when they have
house of mirrors it's used to show the
characters reflecting one another in
kind of their their basically their dual
objectives so bill is obviously wanting
to save this child's life
Pennywise is wanting to kill them and
it's a really nice setting for this
scenario they are sort of reflections of
each other Bill's kind of the guy who
stood up to evil and Pennywise as evil
standing up to good so yeah really nice
subtext here
[Applause]
[Music]
and there we see them back at near bolt
Street hubs and it looks like right
Henry Bowers is back I thought he was
killed in the original film and I was
always a bit curious about it because he
does appear in the source material
basically he goes to an insane asylum
for all the crazy things he did as a kid
and Pennywise makes a bargain with him
that if he kills the losers Club you'll
get him out of there and of course he
signs up so yeah this red blue and it
kind of shows their union and again neo
belt street house which is where they're
gonna face off against our Pennywise
now this is another scene from San Diego
comic-con that was shown basically it's
a massive reference to the thing
apparently out of that fridge burst a
head and this head begins to sprout legs
if you've seen the thing it's one of my
favorite horror movies of all time that
is a massive scene on it and Bill Hader
actually says you gotta be effing
kidding me which is another reference to
thing so yeah glad to see such an
amazing easter egg in the film and
there's 99 red balloons from that song
so when the losers Club are going back
to Derry basically Pennywise doesn't
want them to come back because they
could defeat him so he launches sort of
these attacks against them to kind of
scare them and we do see throughout the
trailer them separated and he's
basically launching an all-out assault
to stop them from going back to the town
[Music]
and if you just go back there a thing
that might be a corpse of the species
that Pennywise is obviously if you read
the source material you know he's a
giant spider sort of that sort of form
he's not a spider but he's sort of
similar to one and this could be the
bones of another one of his species that
landed with him and died
[Music]
so again we see Pennywise sort of doing
his very solo missions to kind of stop
people from coming back to the town this
is obviously before they meet up and
yeah he's launching an all-out assault
against them and sorry I'll just go back
there that was very clearly stands
severed he basically cut his wrists open
after the call with Mike so he's killed
himself and he Scrolls on the wall just
it and this kind of will starts the the
book in a very sort of gripping way so
yeah I can definitely see that there
[Music]
so there's the basement again where
Georgie famously went to in the first
film and also Bill saw the the image of
his brother and his back is taunting him
again and there's the scene that has the
most blood ever used in a film ever
it did top the shining and yet it's good
to see it yeah she's accomplished essica
Chastain is basically completely covered
and yet that's amazing
[Music]
and there's the ritual of chewed em it's
a very esoteric part of the book that
sort of breaks the the dimensions it's
basically an LSD trip they have
confirmed that it is going to be in the
film
now a lot of critics have said it's
going to be a very difficult part film
but they are attempting it and it's very
psychological and yeah it looks like
this is sort of how I'd imagined it to
start off with them all kind of holding
hands but I think they will be able to
pull it off and we will see though but
yeah this this works kind of well for me
[Music]
and I think right now going against my
last video I did say that penny wise
wasn't a real person and so that old
photograph just was wasn't him
but I think they've actually went
against that and have said that at some
point penny wise tried to integrate with
the town by being a clown in the olden
days and this is sort of a clip of that
way kind of realizes that he's not
fitting in and he just goes all out
crazy
so yeah amazing okay so now just on to
some general information about the movie
the cast and storyline so firstly the
film will be released on the 6th of
September worldwide and yeah I'm pretty
hype for it from the first look at the
trailer it's pretty safe to say that
this is sticking very close to the
source material with the losers Club
returning 27 years later to take down
Pennywise the clown since they're packed
in the first film they've all went their
separate ways and the movie will clearly
not only tackle the danger that
Pennywise presents but also how
friendships fracture over the years with
many of the characters not really
wishing to return to what could be their
death Mike now works as a librarian and
dairy bill has become a best-selling
horror novelist Ben is an architect
beverly is a fashion designer and Richie
is a late night television comedian
Eddie runs a limo service and Stan is a
real estate broker they've all pretty
much gone on to lead happy lives as
penny wise promised except maybe Eddie
and Beverly however that doesn't mean
that the earth should be forgotten and
it's pretty clear that Mike will be the
one that has to bring them all together
there is going to be more footage shown
at Comic Con for the film but I think
they really just wanted to get this
trailer out to get people hyped for
those who couldn't attend there was some
photos released the other week that show
the losers Club returning back to the
house where penny wise lives and James
McAvoy is clearly amping them up one big
thing you will notice about these photos
is that Mike has a bandaged arm and this
is likely because he's went toe-to-toe
with penny wise at some point the movie
itself is going to come back and forth
between the old and new cast and this
was confirmed in an interview with James
McAvoy in Entertainment Weekly this is
similar to the book as it's not really
told in linear fashion and anyone who's
read it knows it kind of jumps back and
forth between the past and present now
on to the itch after three rumors that
are currently floating around excuse the
pun so the movie is tracking to do one
hundred and fifty million dollars on
opening weekend and if it hits that and
this will probably Asher it to be the
highest-grossing r-rated movie of all
time if it does do that and you can
pretty much bet that the studio will
want to do more movies set around the
characters and apparently there are some
scripts in production
we'll accomplish this those who read the
book know that Pennywise is eventually
defeated at the end of it so this has
led to a lot of speculation on the
internet surrounding what could actually
happen the director of the film has
actually mentioned that if they go down
this route then the film will in fact be
both a prequel and sequel the firstly
shows that losers clubs children in the
future who are still haunted by penny
wise who will be taunting them for their
parents actions just opposing this the
movie will also show penny wise arriving
on earth and his origin and dairy as
well as how he began to pick off the
pilgrims that journey to the area and
eventually built their settlement there
whilst I am a bit of a king purist
unless we're talking about the shining
movie I definitely think that if they do
go down this route it could work and of
course be there on day one to watch the
movie
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the trailer and the film in general
so make sure that you comment below and
let me know and if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and make sure
you check out my full breakdown of my
strange things three fan theories
surrounding dr. brenner which would be
linked at the end also just want to let
you know that we're giving away a free
copy of the vendor's endgame on blu-ray
to one lucky winner and all you have to
do is like this video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on it chapter two in the
comments section below the wooden will
be chosen at random on August the 10th
and the blu-ray will be shipped out from
then to ever get surprised it's the best
of luck to everyone who takes part this
is the channel for people who were mad
into movies so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace